there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey it's us again and this is
episode 61 yeah isn't that crazy yeah
this is gonna be a show centered around
Florida man yes several different
Florida made Florida man yeah it's
interesting because I had gotten like
requests to do various Florida crimes
and things like that and I thought well
maybe I'll just put them all on one show
and the interesting thing about it is
that the four cases that I'm gonna talk
about on this show I had not heard of
any of them even though I've lived here
my whole entire life isn't that great
they just got lost in the swamp of other
Florida men I guess so it's like you
know you have to do a lot to compete
with yeah you know the whole Florida
Florida man unless you're like wrestling
alligators are eating someone else's
face off yeah Florida has a lot of
diversity it goes all the way up from
the Panhandle all the way down almost to
Cuba yeah you never know what you're
gonna run into in Florida that's
definitely true
yeah it's the new California and I was
born here so you know like I said last
time I'm Florida woman I guess although
I've never done anything like these
people but yeah so these three Kate
these four cases all serial killers
three of them never caught one of them
they think they caught him like they
arrested a guy but he's still on trial
at the moment so I'm gonna do him like
in chronological order I guess yeah I
don't know which ones you do and use it
you gonna do the one by the old guy who
buried the little girl alive now I
remember that dude the guy was a piece
of work that's I mean there's so many
it's like I don't even yeah I'm doing
like I'm doing like for like serial
killers okay he wasn't a serial killer
he only killed one I think so yeah so
that makes it better it was you have to
be to be qualified as a seer
another thing they have to do 3 yeah
right so you either have I think it's
three or you either have to do two that
have like a very specific signature and
they have reason to believe that you
will keep doing that but I think that
more or less it's three and so that's
what we're gonna do cuz like I said I'm
from Florida and these were all
interesting cases to me now I had
actually talked about one of the cases
I'm gonna talk about I actually talked
about on the conspiratorial show which
I'm not sure when that's gonna go up I
recorded an interview with Adam same
from conspiratorial you know we talked
about a bunch of different cases that
were in my new faceless villain 3 book
and I'm on the bonus material yeah you
have to go be their patron to hear Tom
to the show yeah so they know what
questions to ask me they get me to get
me to go off a lot of it had to do with
what Ishita cam and yeah that was fun
Chet oh yeah so so that'll be that thing
now let's do like a couple of shout outs
yeah got a new patron this week named
will s hey there man
thank you very much you know we
appreciate everyone's support also as I
mentioned my book faceless villain 3 is
out on all formats audio book ebook
print etc yeah so I'm pretty well I also
just finished cuz like I said I'm gonna
consolidate like a lot of my fiction
short stories novels things like that
into like bigger volumes and I'm gonna
do audiobook versions of them and you
know do second editions of ones that
were already out like new covers and
[ __ ] like that so my first one of those
associated villainies I just finished
recording and editing the audiobook so
what I'm gonna do is probably by the
time this goes up I probably will have
already put the print and the e-book up
so it might already be available at this
time
and then probably like two weeks from
now the audiobook will be available so
this is like yes so this is like there's
30 short stories in it as I said if you
if you read the first edition
of it this actually has some extra
stories in it so yeah if that's worth it
to you
and I like I said there's an audiobook
version of it which there never was
before so that's kind of neat now since
we were talking about conspiratorial and
if you saw the commercial last week they
are doing like a conference in Tennessee
but you know like all paranormal stuff
and it is on October 19th so if you're
in the area you know and again I'm gonna
run the commercial on the show so you
can listen they got all the details and
stuff like that I just thought I would
mention it on here too just because
they're friends of the show we you know
and I've been on their show a lot of
times we've both been on their show
several times talking about various
topics so go check it out if you're in
that area yeah also here's another thing
that I like it was like time sneaks up
on me man it's like I didn't even
realize it's the almost middle of
September and I'm like well [ __ ] I need
to figure out something to do for the
Halloween show in case we need to do
something that like takes a long time
and someone asked me it's like oh are
you doing like you did on the Halloween
show last year where you had people like
submit stories like ghost stories or
scary stories or scary [ __ ] that
happened to them and I'm like should we
do that again that was kind of fun and a
lot of people who likes that yeah so if
we do do that again then I'll probably I
mean I can say it now I guess but if you
have a scary story that happened to you
or true story fictional story whatever
as long as it's scary and you want us to
read it aloud on the show as long as
it's not super super super long because
we had one was just too long yeah
because there was a couple that were
like too long it'd be like a four or
five hour show yeah it's like what am i
doing like a little bit longer show but
it's like you know I wanted them like
kind of short enough to read on the
thing so uh you know I'll put the thing
in the description like word the email
you can send it to and all that other
kind of stuff so that cat back in there
I think so yeah okay you guys see it
can't go in there yeah
she's always sneaking around there like
behind us and stuff like that little
Pookie what are you doing in there come
here where's she going the closet yeah
okay oh yeah there there's her there's
your little face oh [ __ ] up look at you
move cookie Sheila this alright so I
think that's probably all the shoutouts
yeah yeah alright so let's get into
talking about some murders alright now
as I said I'm going in chronological
order so the first ones we're gonna talk
about are called the flat tire murders
these happened in South Dade County so
now you got tear [ __ ] up in here yeah
come here okay cookie yeah yes so these
are called the flat tire murders they
happen in South Dade County in the 1970s
specifically in 1975 if you are not from
Florida South Dade County is notable for
being the county which contains Miami
yeah so you can get an idea where where
we're talking about so this person who
was never caught
they think that he murdered between five
and nine women in 1975 no suspects were
ever identified case remains unsolved
now the first one of these murders
happened on February 1st 1975 the victim
was 20 year old Judith Esther Lange she
had been all her clothing was gone and
she had been dumped in a canal she had
been working at a massage parlor before
her death the last time she was seen was
when she was leaving the massage part
parlor after her shift at work which was
9:00 p.m. two days before her body was
found she was also known to be a
hitchhiker which is like I said a lot of
people did that in the sixties and
seventies but a lot of people got
murdered doing that too so don't hit you
guys later on the same month which was
very rapid Oh No she's tearing
everything up in there she wants us to
pay a time yeah right I don't know why
you get so much attention I don't know
why your problem is
all right so the second victim was found
later on in February of 1975 this was 23
year old Barbara Stevens now she was
actually kidnapped from a mall and then
later found stabbed to death now I've
seen varying accounts of where this body
was found some said she was found like
out in the open some said she was found
in her house which would lead one to
believe that maybe these weren't
connected but the thing that gave this
serial killer his name was that when the
investigators found this woman's car
like in the parking lot of the mall one
of the tires had been let down so that
was something that would kind of come up
again like in later cases so he's
pulling like a Bundy type of thing where
he's dude he's like [ __ ] up some
people's car and then when they come up
and they can't then he's like oh hey can
I help you with your car right - ruse
and then they murder you yeah so they
think that's what this dude was doing
the next one occurred on April 12th 1975
this was a 17 year old girl named
Arrieta tinker now she was found in a
canal not too far away from where the
first victim had been found
she was actually married despite her
young age her and her husband had a
one-year-old son but yes so she was the
third victim then there was like kind of
a gap of several months then there was
June 15 1975 this girl named Nancy Lee
Fox she was 19 she worked as a waitress
at a taco place and she got off her
shift at the restaurant and started
walking home she lived in Fort
Lauderdale actually and she disappeared
subsequently on the walk home
they found her what's that he must he
must be seeing these women at work
that's kind of what I'm thinking is
following them mm-hmm
following to where they're going I mean
when they go somewhere
gets it up to the parking lot of where
they're gonna shop and then lets the air
out of the tire yeah and he could then
they come back out and then he offers to
help him yeah I need a particular one
easy we were to talk about urges they
just said a taco restaurant so I don't
know why choco bill maybe what year do
you say what seventy son 1975 Taco Bell
yeah del Taco not that early
yeah although it could have been like a
mom-and-pop could have been they were
more rare back then back then you know
true although in Miami or Fort
Lauderdale it's far from Mexico
California baby yeah that was growing up
during that time it had been a chain and
it probably been taco taco bell yeah and
he went in there to get some tacos and
saw that's what that's what happened
there
yeah he's seeing him where they work
where the other ones work say one worked
at a massage parlor that was just one he
ran across a customer there maybe and
then another one was like not at work
she was shopping at a mall cuz I don't
know it certain places at certain times
that massage parlors a euphemism for a
brothel that's what's going on in there
well I thought that Robert was ugh but
that's what I thought was mostly going
on in this place
maybe that's I don't know you're getting
one myself I don't know how how you know
open they are about that tech that's
illegal
yeah it is have you send the Vice unit
after them you know they can bust them
yeah and I remember some in Daytona
being busted me yes growing up there so
I you have to have very tolerant cops
for that to go down so I don't know they
just see he's you know serial killer
would be the kind of guy who would
typically kind of you know I go check
out places where you know a lot lizards
or hookers or something where that you
know you go to massage parlor and look
yeah I get one so he's a guy who's
patrolling yeah he definitely seems like
one that's I'm just going out and like
hunting he's patrolling in various
places he's gonna be kind of like a
Dennis Rader diaper what was it the guy
who well now I wouldn't try to find a
good example of one that does that no it
doesn't matter
audience knows who it is I'm talking
about yeah yeah Dennis from Dennis Rader
really didn't hunt that way no that's
true Gary Ridgway did yeah probably
something more like that
I feel like Rader didn't he generally
his thing was more like location-based
yeah a little bit he was him into good
good girls actually yeah church women
and just people that worked you know
lived in the neighborhood I don't I
don't think was interested in hookers
Gary Ridgway was but this guy here you
know he's I think he's just just targets
of opportunity yeah it's like did a girl
that worked here the girl that worked
there you know yeah it seems like he's
just kind of like oh no he happened to
be in a taco bow one day and saw
somebody was like oh yeah he's looking
for women yeah that's what he was doing
in a damn massage parlor yeah yeah so
yeah so this woman Nancy Lee Fox who was
19 as I said she was later found dumped
in the same canal where Judith Esther
Lange who was the first victim was found
now she had also been stripped naked she
had been raped and she had actually been
killed by being hit with a blunt object
so he's changing up his MO a little bit
if indeed this is the same person cuz at
least one of the other ones was stabbed
and then some of the other ones were
beaten in the head
now the next ones this only occurred
three days later was the stab wound
earlier yeah yeah found out that wasn't
effective yeah maybe that's what it was
amiss she died but I mean yeah it takes
too long yeah blunt force trauma knocks
about instantly yeah we were talking
about that in regards to dread Kemper
yeah how you you think you can just stab
a person one time and they're just gonna
like keel over dead enough know how it
works
no they fight back for a long time -
yeah stab wounds it just takes a long
time to bleed out from that just a knife
is just not a good weapon it's a great
tool yeah you know main thing soldiers
carry bayonets and [ __ ] like that and
knives on them they're not killing
people with those yeah they're cutting
cords and cutting wire and making cap
with them you know I feel like a lot of
serial killers probably use them not
because they're efficient but because
they're
you know a penetrative so this they're
scary you know there's something
something that they grew up seeing yeah
and had all this detective magazines
which featured knives a lot on the
covers and you know I mean it's kind of
an intimidating thing I got a knife [ __ ]
man a [ __ ] Club is better than the
knife actually yeah but I think like I
said there's definitely some kind of
fetishistic element to it because I mean
that's why the killers in jell-o movies
and a lot of slasher movies always use
no cruel related weapons
yes cruel and sharp-looking you know
what I mean it's pointed and it's you
know just stabbed into you yeah it makes
blood you can slice somebody you know
well yeah they're not that effective
like I said I don't know if a lot of
them are going for effectiveness SS
airily yeah mostly just probably you
know intimidate somebody get him to obey
yeah so the next two victims and this
only happened like a few days after
Nancy Lee Fox was killed now these were
two 14 year old girls
Barbara Schreiber and Belinda Zetas our
I just realized something
what's that I was thinking a raider
because her name is Nancy Fox that was
the name of one of Dennis Rader's
victims remember even deep called on the
phone yeah Nancy Fox yeah
her last name was Fox I can't remember
for a first name with an T or not it
might have been yeah I think it was yeah
wouldn't that be creepy if like this
more than one serial killer like well
that happened in [ __ ] the alphabet
murders too like one of the victims in
New York was named Carmen Cologne and
then one of the victims in California
was also named Carmen Cologne which and
it's probably a coincidence cuz I don't
know if that was the same killer or not
hmm
but yeah so these were two 14 year old
girls they were seen hitchhiking at
about 10:00 p.m. on June 18th and a
couple of days later were found murdered
their bodies dumped side by side in a
Broward canal they had all been stripped
they had both been stripped naked had
both been raped now these two were shot
with a heavy caliber handgun when was
shot in the head and the other one was
shot in the chest so like I said if this
is the same killer I mean it seems like
the same victim profile more or less
seems like the same kind of and he's
dumping them in pretty
much the same place he's just using
different weapons that way I guess so
now the next one happened three weeks
later this was July 10th and this was
another teenage girl 15 year old Robin
Losh she was found in the same canal you
know and this canal like I said was the
same it was like 200 yards from the
canal where the where two of the other
victims were found a sterling at Fox now
unusually for this particular killer
Robin Losh was actually found fully
clothed but they think that it was
probably the same there were other
aspects of the case that made him think
that it was probably the same plus the
body had been dumped in pretty much the
same place as a bunch of the other ones
so they thought that maybe this killer
was either lived around there or worked
around there something like that because
he seemed very comfortable in this area
and like comfortable dumping bodies
there I need clothes because maybe she
started to run away he shot her maybe
she fought back yeah yeah because most
of the other ones were or naked and most
of the other ones are raised you know if
a guy's gonna do this to you you might
as well just go down fighting that's
what I always thought yeah force him to
kill you
I would rather you know it's it's just
horrible to think about well you know
you can stay Stu statistically they you
know they mostly let him go so I guess
that's what they're holding on to him
you don't know you if you're with one
one of them's got a hold year that he's
gonna kill you but man safe to assume
he's probably gonna rape you and kill
you I would assume that yeah I would
kind of assume that and I would rather
allegis try to go down fighting go down
to your [ __ ] boots on shoot me
[ __ ] you know that are trying to
take him out why would you know how big
these guys are you don't know that - I'm
just saying yeah at least you can film
this you could maybe [ __ ] hurt him
before I'm feeling this is a young guy
most of them are yeah you know yeah
because you know some were 15 16 17 he's
probably not much older than that yeah I
may be wrong though cuz it seemed like
most of his victims were he's going to
massage parlours younger yeah he sounds
like a guy who's early twenties probably
so the next victim was Ronnie Goran she
was 27 years old on July 22nd 1975 her
car was found in a shopping mall parking
lot in North Miami with one of the tires
let out the airline out the next day her
body was found in the same canal clothes
removed except for her shoes she had
sandals on and he left the sandals on
but she was naked other than that and
also she had been raped I don't know how
she was killed
eight days later 21-year old
Elise Knapp was in founded a canal about
a mile away from where the last victim
had been found now she had actually been
hit on the back of the head and then
drowned so I'm not sure like drowned
like hit her on the back of the head and
then like throw her in the canal so I'm
guessing she just was unconscious
because they said that the wound would
have caused a concussion
she was also found naked the only thing
that was left on her body was a necklace
that had a little charm on it so she and
had she had actually been a secretary so
the these victims are not like because
some of the ones I'm going to talk about
later like some of the victims were you
know prostitutes or drug addicts or
something like that but these ones were
were not that so her car was also found
with a flat tire as I said in the
parking lot of the Hollywood shopping
center now August 17th 1975 there was
another body and this was this one was
found like in a rock pit like a quarry
hold on one second what's that so her
car was found at the shopping center
parking lot of the shop instead of her
so he's offering to give her a ride
somewhere huh he's doing to fix the car
yeah something like that yeah he said
yeah I'll give he probably said yeah
I'll give you a ride to like service to
the service station and you can like
figure out what to do or I'll give you
you know or I'll give you a rose or
something yeah or something like that so
yeah that's what he's doing now this
this victim
her name was her name is just given as
mrs. Gordon her car was actually found
in the same parking lot as the car
belonging to Bern in Berlin but the
tires weren't deflated now when they
found her body in the rock pit she had
all her clothes on too so they weren't
entirely sure if this was the same
killer even though the mo was similar
but different enough that they were kind
of like you know they weren't entirely
sure so at this point they felt like at
least five of these particular killings
were likely the same person and then
there were a few more that were like you
know kind of out sided that could have
been the same person but the mo was
slightly different like the way they
were killed and stuff now another
interesting thing that they noticed was
that some things that were reported some
similarities they said obviously a lot
of the cars were found with a you know
found at a parking lot or found with
their tires flat some of them were
rental cars or leased cars and they had
what they called etags almost either all
or almost all of the victims were Jewish
which they thought was very interesting
most of the victims that were found
naked had one item left on them either a
piece of jewelry or a pair of shoes or
something like that so they weren't sure
if it was like some kind of fetishistic
sort of thing you know what I mean but
one were Jewish um I actually maybe all
of them were Jewish so this had a common
ethnicity of that era that's what I mean
I don't I'm not really sure maybe he
just had their with it maybe they just
Jewish girls had a certain look that he
liked he might have been Jewish yeah
because a lot of times they stick within
their ethnic group yeah most of the time
they do so I bet you that [ __ ] she was
Jewish yeah and that maybe that was just
your average dumb ass white boy wouldn't
know what a Jewish girl would probably
look like back in those days in Florida
true yeah yeah I mean that would stand
to reason wouldn't it yes
yeah usually serial killers will pick
victim is based on you have to know what
Jewish people look like to know how you
know I mean yeah you know I think the
average white people don't don't even
know what judge people really look like
this the kind of white people well yeah
but if people could spot all the Jewish
people Jewish yeah he might have been
yeah I mean that would sit
you know since all or most of the
victims were Jewish I would imagine that
the killer is probably Jewish as well
that's right start yeah so if they if
indeed this was all the same person a
variety of different methods were used
now some of them were shot like I said
some of them were hit in the head they
think with a hammer
the ones that were stabbed they think
that maybe it was an ice pick which is
kind of weird but you know that's that's
what they're thinking it these are the
same it's this is the same guy they just
think it's somebody that was trying to
change up their MO but then they're all
dumped then he's dumping all the bodies
in the same place and he's not
particularly trying to hide them because
they all seemed like they were found
like almost immediately it wasn't like
he was burying him or nothing right so
you know my money says my money is that
there's a Jewish guy this is somebody
who could spot another Jewish person
yeah don't even have another name yeah
made Bank oh that's that's Jewish person
yeah
as a Jewish girl yeah I bet you did
Jewish guy yeah it may be like I said
although they never got him now at the
time that these were these crimes were
going on in 1975 there was this one guy
who was a sergeant in Sonoma County
named erlin Carlstedt and he's like I
think this is the same person who has
been doing some other murders in
Washington and Utah and that he had been
like traveling back and forth from the
opposite coasts
however as anyone who's super into true
crime will be aware the murder the
specific murders that he was talking
about that occurred in Utah were
committed by Ted Bundy now some people
speculate that Ted Bundy might have
killed these girls as well in Florida
because he did you know he was in
Florida for it
and it did sort of like over look like
it was possible that he could have been
in Florida like when that [ __ ] was going
on and everything but that ethnic factor
right that's what I mean and the thing
is he confessed to like a whole bunch of
murders like before you know they gave
him the chair and those ones were not
among the ones that he confessed to so
you would think that he would have
professed up if that was him
yeah although this does see the reason
they thought that maybe it was him
because of the whole car ruse because
that was a very Bundy ask yeah thing you
know cuz he would do that same kind of
[ __ ] to it so you have a caster of you
know yeah he might have heard about that
from fun that's what I mean so the the
guy that's doing this I must say the
ethnic angle I would exclude him well I
would say buddy didn't have a thing for
Jewish girls he liked girls that looked
like Marcia Brady yeah basically long
hair I think he preferred blond women
but I think he took any any anyone well
I thought that I thought it was dark
hair but the dark I don't have some kind
of I think was straight hair though with
yeah like parted and hardened in the
middle yeah I remember that you know his
victim profile they were they were all
similar looking they were all
good-looking yeah but they were Anglo
yeah yeah and he was like he mostly
hunted around college campuses yeah
whereas this guy seems like like you
said he was just randomly going into
places and seeing a girl that worked
there someone that was shopping at a
mall or something and then decided to
yeah I remember reading you know books
or had a lot of Bundy's quotes in it you
know when guys were interviewing him and
yeah but he was a snob he saw himself as
like upper crust
yeah serial killer if she wasn't a
college girl or something from a good
family then she was garbage she wasn't
worth killing yeah he likes the cream of
the crop you know he made fun of serial
killers that went after prostitutes a
[ __ ] like that call him body
bottom-feeders yeah that anybody could
do that doesn't require any skill you
don't have to be a man of taste you know
that's basically what he said anyway
cancer had a bit of that too where it's
like he's he's
not the killers that went after
prostitutes or drug addicts or something
like that where yeah gum better scum
right or that was like too easy or
something I don't know that's [ __ ] up
it's pretty [ __ ] up they're like even
serial killers have like a hierarchy
yeah a Bundy thought that you know the
ultimate high caliber serial killers
supposed to be intelligent charming and
handsome and supposed to be able to get
the prettiest girls in the world to go
with him somewhere for you know
willingly and that you know the he could
be able to trick them pretty easily you
know and he was manipulative yeah but he
judged himself based upon the quality of
his victims yeah you know the heart of
the the higher caliber they were the
better he was yeah that you know he
didn't to belittle himself by going
after you know street trash yeah I mean
you know that's I can see that actually
you know what I mean because that's I
guess he considered that his work you
know what I mean and it's like oh I
guess he kind of saw it in the way that
a guy would see it about datin girls
yeah in his cases rape or murder yeah
but you know I mean a guy who's I take
that girl you know I mean he's like -
she fugly yeah yeah she's scuzzy I'll
kill that one but I'm gonna kill this
one kill that nice girl over yeah
that'sthat's what he was that's the way
that's a messed up why it's I think you
know what Syria
serial killers it's us it's a what do
you call it it's a sexual orientation
yeah it does seem it is a sexual
orientation yeah it's like they take the
normal [ __ ] about you like who you want
to date and [ __ ] like that but they just
extrapolate that's a like hey I'm gonna
kill him
yeah rape and murder but it's that same
sex drive it's that same orientation
basically yeah yeah they're killing what
they would normally date yeah or marry
yeah yeah that's crazy yeah yeah so like
I said the what I was gonna say I guess
it's what they would date or marry but
not quite because they you know what you
know Gary Ridgway was married to a
normal woman but he killed
but just like trashy yeah hookers well
yeah some serial killers are married to
like a normal could beat it Bundy would
say was cuz he was a [ __ ] dumbass and
a scuzzbag he couldn't get a nice woman
right that's what so he had to go with
hookers cuz that's the only person
people that would go with him so I guess
he was I guess Bundy would probably say
that the Green River Killer was he was
only killing hookers cuz that was the
only kind of women he could get yeah
that's it was done a show back area
which rich way halfway no yeah we're
yeah we yeah little [ __ ] weasel we
need to get around to doing it yeah we
got to do Richards back to he gets in
because I read way it was the weakest of
the serial killers if he asked me I mean
although one of the most prolific hey
killed a lot of him but he look at that
guy was just like it's like a serial
killer version of what Rick Moranis my
fella Rick didn't he did not read
somewhere wasn't it Gary Ridgway that
like in the area that he was in like
skewed the average like crap for the
crime rate crime rate because it killed
so many people
yeah that's [ __ ] up although think I
see the lot on the show
[Laughter]
the cops had interviewed him just said
they were just amazed at how how weak he
was yeah yeah he's extremely weak man
there's well in a monster it doesn't
take much to yeah well they were
expecting kind of like a real monster
but he was really more like a nobody
yeah you know well a lot of them end up
being like yeah I don't know why people
keep expecting them to me to like look
like an ogre or something well he was
just a real meat nobody did you yeah but
you know you wouldn't you wouldn't think
that that's you know would be a multiple
murderer or a serial killer you would
think that it would be somebody to help
you know big anger issues and you know
the main thing somebody who looked
amazing you know know it hardly ever is
though yeah dweeb yeah well like I said
a lot of them are so as I said now the
flat tire murders between five and nine
victims never solved no suspects no
nothing that was that was the only
theory that maybe it was Bundy and then
they were like now
probably wasn't Bundy and that's been
the end of it and like I've lived here
my whole life I was three years old when
this [ __ ] happened and I had never heard
of these there's like a [ __ ] serial
killer running around in the 70s when I
was little and I didn't even know
anything he either moved away although
if he'd moved away he'd gotten caught
either left brought that same signature
with him he'd been caught and then he
would have confessed to those yeah now
I'm kind of wondering I think he stopped
I'm betting yeah because he did stuff on
me because these all happened like in a
fairly short time it was less than a
year yeah he might he might have burned
out yeah and realized that there was he
had some kind of weird fetish about it
did it a few times and maybe he got
satisfied or he realized that he was
chasing a dragon you know I mean that he
would never be satisfied so he stopped I
mean I guess yeah you know maybe it
satisfy his curiosity if it didn't
fulfill him yeah I agree I mean I guess
they always say like oh serial killer
like particular types of serial killers
never stop and stuff like that but I
think someone do yeah I think I mean I
don't think they necessarily all die or
move away or it might have been pretty
young they got in a car with him so
maybe he was young and basically kind of
cute and non-threatening yeah so they
got into a car with him when he tried to
help him raped and killed some of them
and then he realized then for some
reason decided there was nothing to it
didn't want to do it anymore [ __ ] man he
could still be living around here
somewhere catch him no I guess not
like I said unless he got caught for
some other [ __ ] and never liked fest up
to this but I got away with it yeah
that's what I'm thinking or he died
maybe he got away with it and then he
died but he didn't die back then he
stopped yeah yeah I believe it this just
that I'm thinking about this now I'm
just like creeping me out because I'm
like holy crap it's like somebody's this
[ __ ] happened in [ __ ] time you might
still be running a restaurant
it's that Jewish angle to that ethnic
Jewish angle he was going after women of
his own ethnic background yeah and you
know just people have higher than
average the national average IQ II was
smart yeah and serial killers tend to be
small
he was young and [ __ ] dumb and he had
this in him and he went out and did it a
couple times and then decided that you
know it really wasn't satisfying him and
he'd eventually get caught so he stopped
yeah I don't you I bet that's what
happened yeah probably I'm trying Betty
he did something like become a cop that
would not shock me yeah like old
what's-his-name yeah yeah what's his
name a Night Stalker original Night
Stalker yeah don't state killer
Joseph D'Angelo yeah allegedly I did I
tell you what I don't know if I said it
on the show I think I said it on the
conspiratorial thing but it's like I
happen to see like a headline about
D'Angelo the other day and they had a
picture of him and I was like who the
[ __ ] says that's not D'Angelo but it was
he's gonna like a hunger strike or some
[ __ ] like he lost like all this what
he's like unrecognizable I think he
stopped and became a cop or he or he did
something maybe he got married maybe he
joined the army and moved away and
developed a different personality he
might have been really young when he did
it yeah something like that
he stopped there's a good chance he
stopped at a time when he was still
pretty young where he could change yeah
or hold it you know I mean in check
maybe was some early in his development
he might have been a teenager when he
did this yeah it did seem like I mean
not all of the victims were teenagers
but they went with a significant portion
of them were they went with him which
makes me think that he was not
threatening looking yeah well yeah
that's what I mean these serial killers
again get away with a lot of this stuff
for like a long time and everything it's
like they can't look like a big [ __ ]
ogre because then they wouldn't be able
to like Laura anyone into their car
except people like No thank you for all
you for all we know he was 17 18 19 year
old and he was cute yeah wonder if I I
wonder if I know this but I don't sleep
[Laughter]
well we're gonna get like later on we're
gonna get to one where it's like
happened where I grew up and where I was
still living at the time you know
me and so but before we do that we're
gonna talk about the king fish boat ramp
murders alright now this is actually in
my book
because this is also unsolved this
happened over on the west coast of
Florida a little island off the coast of
Tampa where I also lived for a short
time Tampa that is this happened in 1980
now this was the due moi family the dad
was named Wanda moi he was a
pediatrician and he had a wife named
Maria and they had four kids two of whom
were like older teenagers and two
younger boys so it's the beginning of
August and they decide they're gonna go
on summer vacation so they rent a
vacation cottage on this little island
it's like a seven mile island called
Anna Maria Island which is off the west
coast of Florida right like right off of
Tampa so they go when they're staying in
this little vacation cottage or whatever
and then they took their boat and they
you know going out boating and fishing
and everything so Friday August 1st some
of them are gonna go fishing now it's
dr. Jim wah the pediatrician his
brother-in-law who's name is Raymond
barrows and the two younger kids who
were named Eric and Mark and they were
13 and 9 so they go out to the king fish
boat ramp they go out fishing and catch
a whole bunch of fish they come back
like later in the afternoon about 3 or 4
o'clock and you know they hitch the boat
to the back of the car and they're gonna
start to drive back to the vacation
cottage so just as they take off this
random dude pushing a bicycle like kind
of comes out of the bushes and he
started like Flags the car down like he
needs help
so doctor Jim was like hey man what you
need and he's like oh you know it's like
um I hurt my ankle and it's like really
hurting too right to ride this bike and
I can't really walk all that well I just
need a ride to this condominium complex
it's just right up there around the
corner right so this guy's just came up
on the bike so the doctor is like okay
man no problem the doctor gets out of
the
he puts the guy's bike like he loads it
into the boat and then the guy gets into
the backseat of the car with the two
kids and then they start driving toward
the dudes destination minutes later the
dude suddenly pulls out a gun and starts
shooting
he shoots Raymond barrows first who I
presume was in the passenger seat then
he shoots the thirteen-year-old kid and
the nine-year-old kid right in the head
and then he shoots dr. Jim wah who was
driving the car obviously the car kind
of starts to careen and let go off the
road the guy then grabs the wheel of the
car and steers the car off and like
pulls it off onto the shoulder then he
very calmly gets out of the car gets his
bicycle out of the boat and pedals off
toward a grocery store this is the
middle of the afternoon it's like it's
like 4:30 5:00 in the afternoon some
kind of thrill kill so yeah now the
shit's not over though because so the
guy like rides his bike towards this
grocery store
now hold on what so he does this on the
road yeah before they get to the grocery
store yeah and this is in traffic cars
are going by or as or is the traffic
very you know as far well I'm not sure
because I think it was like a parking
lot because they had just come in from
like there's a boat ramp right you know
what I mean and they had just loaded up
the boat on the back of the car and then
this guy kind of came out so I'm
assuming it was like a parking lot or
like a big open area like they usually
have it like a marina or something and
then he was going on the road toward
where this condominium thinking now are
we on a country road this is an island
on an island and it's like near the
water it's like right near the Gulf so
there may be there may have been no
witnesses to this well I'm gonna get
that order because it makes you wonder
Here I am I'm the guy I'm in this card
I'm gonna shoot and kill these people
while the dudes driving this is this is
quite a reach think about it yeah you're
gonna shoot a dude why he's drive and
shoot his whole family while he's
driving
yeah yeah just run the car off the road
you know you'd be killed pretty in
pretty easily in a situation like that
yeah then there's other witnesses
everywhere and then you're just gonna
get out right away like nothing happened
you've got to be insane that's kind of
what kind of insane because like I said
I mean this this is crazy you're gonna
get God you think yeah he didn't know he
didn't but you would think more alert
thinking you it was luck
that's pure luck too he didn't get
caught yeah so what happens after that
now it so happened that like I said the
guy had gotten out of the car and he'd
gone on his bike and started riding away
now there was a guy named Robert Matt
ski he was a retired Air Force
lieutenant colonel now he lived on the
island and he happened to be in the
front yard of his condominium and he saw
the car like swerving and like going off
the side of the road and he saw the guy
get out now he didn't know that anyone
had been shot in the car he just thought
something was the matter with the car or
they'd been in an accident or something
like that so and so he says he calls
back to his wife who's inside the house
he says hey called the police I think
there's been a car accident I'm gonna go
see if everyone's all right or whatever
so he gets in his car and he starts
following the dude on the bike now as he
pulls up alongside the dude on the bike
and it's like hey man you know what
happened back there you all right
everything like that the dude on the
bike pulls out a gun and shoots that guy
in the head as well while he's driving
now the truck that Robert masky is
driving obviously kind of swerves off
and hits another car in a group in the
grocery store parking lot now this
sequence of events was witnessed by a
woman who was coming out of the grocery
store and again she didn't know anyone
had been shot she just saw a car
accident so she called the cops
now when the cops arrived they were
investigating what they thought was two
car accidents so they didn't immediately
like close off the scene or anything
like they didn't know it was a murder at
first they just thought it was two car
accidents so what ended up happening was
that all these kind of good Samaritans
and stuff like that they're around in
the area we're like helping like get the
bodies out of the car
they were all dead yeah well um no
Raymond barrows did live he had been
shot in the head but everyone else was
dead so um so they're pulling all the
bodies out of the cars and then finally
the cops realize holy [ __ ] they've all
been shot you know cuz they just thought
they'd been a winner to accident cuz it
was just blood everywhere and by that
point it's like you know everyone's
already touched everything they've all
touched all the bodies they've all
touched the cars it also happened that
where the car had come to rest like on
the shoulder of the road there was like
a sprinkler head come on and it kind of
like washed a bunch of [ __ ] off the car
so if there was any you know um the
weapon I'm not sure about they did get a
description of the guy which I will get
to in a little bit because several
people did see him now the same woman
that called in the what they thought was
the second car accident with Robert
Matt's Keys car hitting the other car in
the parking lot she said that the guy on
the bicycle had gotten into the backseat
of a tan Ford with a black top that was
driven by another man who she couldn't
really see cuz he was just shadowed and
the vehicle had like taken off my cheek
he took the bike yeah he put it like in
the trunk so he's not apparently he's
not in any hurry and he wasn't alone
yeah he had like another guy like
waiting there for him it was some kind
of spree killing yeah it's like super
weird yeah now another thing that
happened and like I said this is a
summer afternoon like a Friday afternoon
like on a vacation island
you know there's condos all around there
there's vacation cottages all around
there so there's people all over the
place now someone else did see the first
thing like the first thing that they
thought was the car accident like the
car going out the side of the road with
the four people in it now this guy
happened to be a person named John Toth
now he owned a TV repair shop on the
island he was also an amateur
photographer and he had his camera with
him all the time so when he saw the guy
getting out of the car he instinctively
took a picture now hit so it turned out
that he did get a picture of the killer
however
because he was in a hurry or he wasn't
thinking about it he forgot to turn on
the autofocus so there is a picture of
the killer but it's super blurry and
they couldn't tell who it was so as I
said Raymond barrows who was dr. Jim waz
brother-in-law he lived but everyone
else died dr. doom wah died the two boys
died and Robert Maske II the guy that
you know the second guy the Air Force
colonel who went after the guy on the
bike he also died that's some weird [ __ ]
so yeah so they did like a big sweep of
the island you know they you know went
everywhere else in Florida like looking
for this person now they're trying to
come up with a motive because this is
some crazy [ __ ] it's like who the [ __ ]
does this it's just in the middle of the
[ __ ] day with like people everywhere
and doesn't sound like he was by himself
yeah and like he had like a getaway
driver it's almost kind of sounds like
something a small cult would do I mean
some people have thought that maybe it
was a hit um stuff I've read they're
like oh well maybe the brother-in-law
was like involved with some illegal [ __ ]
like a drug cartel or something like
that because they said well he was the
first one shot so maybe he was the
target
sounds very unlike but I'm like well
here's the thing if you sit in a car
with two men in the front seat and two
kids in the back seat I mean you would
shoot the passenger first then the kids
then the driver I mean you don't want to
shoot the driver first because the car
might [ __ ] up and then everyone's gonna
usually get out usually if it's a some
kind of mob hit whoever's gonna be
killed as well known by the Peter
Buffett yeah so they know right where
they live right they don't have to do
something like that what they do is they
just invite themselves over for some
kind of friendly dinner
they all hang out yeah you don't even
know it's coming you think everything's
all right you turn your back they put a
bullet in the back your head yeah it's
like boy I know why would they do it
like in the middle of the day like in a
car it just seems like so much could
have gone wrong if it was a professional
hit it doesn't seem all that
professional it was some kind of spree
killing something maybe between two
young guys some kind of weird fantasy
they had cooked up in their head they
might have been slightly nuts
yeah aliens you know they think aliens
are taking over yeah baby they were just
crazy crazy [ __ ] I mean like I
said they were trying to like they were
trying to come up with anything really
because they wanted to like catch the
person you know they thought well dr.
Jim Wong had actually escaped from
Castro's Cuba it's like maybe it had
something to do with that he was a
pediatrician they even like went so far
as to say well he was a pediatrician
maybe he didn't like treat a kid and his
parents got like pissed off as like they
were just like really grasping at straws
yeah their trend that's almost like
victim blaming it was random yeah I I
feel like it probably was you
these two guys wanted to kill some
people for the thrill of it something
yeah it because it's just I can't think
of a possible reason that doesn't sound
completely insane they didn't know this
dude it's like um you know there was a
description of him they said he was like
a lean muscular dude he was about six
feet tall white guy blue eyes cleft chin
they said he had real thick brown hair
like combed back off his forehead gonna
be something dumb yeah that's gonna be
something dumb you know I mean it was
just like they did it on a dare type of
deal they were just nuts you know yeah I
mean they did have a couple of suspects
they did pick up this one guy whose name
was Richard Lee Whitley and he was
actually originally from Chicago but
like not long after the kingfish boat
ramp murders happened they arrested him
in Tampa because the FBI wanted him for
a murder that had happened in Falls
Church Virginia which was I don't think
it was like super similar but you know
he was in the area at the time now the
other guy that they picked up was named
William Kuhlman or Coleman or however
you say it now he had actually been
accused of murdering a woman in
Bradenton Florida which is very near
Tampa so I think it's a little bit north
of there and it was the same caliber
weapon which is a 22 okay so yeah again
now he got acquitted of that murder but
because of the similarity of in the you
know in the firearm then he got picked
up for this but he was
you know he was dismissed for this one
too so this case and what I was doing
the conspiratorial show this was one of
the ones that he was like super
interested and was asking me about just
because this kind of [ __ ] just like very
very rarely it's just random like that
it was some kind of [ __ ] yeah it's
just some kind of [ __ ] some good you
know two guys got high yet I mean we're
talking about killing people and they
had some kind of weird fantasy and they
worked themselves into it and you'd be
the getaway driver I'll be the it's
something dumb yeah it's like just some
dumb really dumb yeah because I mean it
definitely does seem like this dude just
like wanders out of a bush like with a
bike or something is like hey let me get
in your car it was pre-planned somehow
the guy thing you know cuz what's the
chances he you just like shooting two
carloads of people right and then just
happen to catch a ride yeah they put my
bike in your back in your car you know I
mean catching a rut can't catch up catch
a ride from a stranger
yeah it's just know that dude knew him
yeah he was in on it
well yeah clearly I mean it really
looked like I mean from the woman's
description she basically said yeah he
just totally I don't even know she if
the guy asked the driver just like threw
his bike in the back and then like got
in the [ __ ] car and took off they
took off so yeah it was two guys working
together to kill some people just for
shits and giggles some past real kill
that's what makes this like really crazy
because there's like no like I said
there's no possible motive for that they
didn't know the guy and I mean even
though Raymond barrows lived the
brother-in-law I mean I'm assuming they
questioned him extensively about who the
person was that if he knew them and
stuff like that but if he didn't know
them I mean they knew what he looked
like they had a description but because
a bunch of people saw him but nothing it
was just some [ __ ] thing that these
died these guys cooked up they just
decided that they were just gonna go
shoot yeah one day yeah you'll go crazy
trying to read into it was just some
[ __ ] well it's not so much that I'm
trying to read into it it's just that
it's just it's
really unusual it's just an unusual
couple of [ __ ] psychos that were
bored they just wanted to kill some
people well yeah I guess I guess no all
right so we're almost at an hour so I
guess we'll take a break right now when
we come back I'm gonna talk about the
Daytona Beach Killer which I don't even
know about this [ __ ] and I'm
from Daytona Beach and I lived there
when this was going on even though I
don't really remember hearing about it
so it's like all the [ __ ] so I was like
reading about it I'm like oh my god I
know exactly where that is oh my god I
know exactly where that is it was like
freaking me out
so yeah so we will talk about that when
we come back and we're gonna take a
break and we'll be back in a minute
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the Caddy
murders the carry babies case the Frog
Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
what's up baby cookie are you trying to
give the bubbles you're trying to get
the bubbles how's that working out for
you yeah what you're doing what you do
you can you push on it no way can we no
look look there's bubbles in there
there's bubbles in there you need to get
off you need to get off you know Oh
push it push it oh you'll get him to
come out you'll get him to come in
conspiratorial podcasts proudly presents
the strange realities conference range
reality
come join us for one day of
presentations on the paranormal of live
music at night featuring Tim the knob
the rise and fall of the Flat Earth
theory
Joshua kuchen alien hybrid Lord
Joe d'marie pushing the limits of
reality
Roswell 1947 what really happened
Timothy Ritter Pennsylvania Wildman and
added to the lineup Marc Anthony Wyatt
Cornish legends and UFO sighting Zach
hunt
presentation of his book on drought
followed by a live recording at the
conspiratorial podcast more speakers and
music acts to be announced October 19
2019 si our nationís info at wwlp.com
$40 at the door
30 bucks presale
[Music]
I'm right we're back for the second half
the show talking about Florida crime now
this one really wigged me out because
this [ __ ] right here occurred in my
hometown my birthplace Daytona Beach and
it happened while I was living there and
I don't remember hearing about it
hmmm what years were taught mom 2005 to
2007 okay yeah and this is like yeah
it's recent and this is a serial killer
killed at least four people and never
caught we're watching the news I guess I
wasn't I was though
how could I miss this I don't know it's
like really really strange but yeah so
as I said this occurred from 2005 to
2007 in Daytona Beach Florida I'm gonna
have to put up a picture of Halifax
Hospital in Daytona Beach Florida where
I was born
just cuz so you so you can get an idea
of like what a look where you were born
yeah okay I'm just like what it looks
like you know alright now the first
victim of the Daytona Beach killer they
didn't give him like a cool nickname or
anything which I guess I'm glad that
they're not really doing that anymore
now they just kind of like named you
after like wherever you're killing
people at like the Long Island serial
killer they're not giving you like cool
[ __ ] nicknames like the seventies
anymore right
they're not giving you like badass them
actually there's a news media that gave
those people those names ya know yeah
like I said I'm glad they're not really
doing that anymore I think that I think
they actually did come out and
discourage that I think like cops and
FBI and stepper like please stop
encouraging them just like call them a
place name or call them something boring
so they just said this guy they're just
calling him the Daytona Beach killer so
the first victim now I was gonna say too
when we're talking about Daytona Beach I
mean I think when people talk about true
crime and Daytona Beach II always so I
think about alien war knows right yeah
but she needs her own show so that's why
we're not talking about around this one
yeah and this was this was a serial
killer that I had never heard of before
so when everybody knows who Aileen
Wuornos is but we will do a show about
her eventually because she has kind of
an interest
character so the first victim of the
Daytona Beach killer was a 45 year old
sex worker by the name of laquetta
Gunther now she was a known drug user
she did day labor and stuff like that to
frequented bars along get old North
Ridgewood Avenue which I'm very familiar
with that's where all the streetwalkers
hang out but I used to go down there all
the time too because there was I don't
think it's there anymore but they used
to be this really kick-ass store called
Judy's jazzy boutique and it was run by
these this really old lady and her
daughter and they had like the bet that
that's where like you got all your good
goth clothes like all your Rockstar
clothes Jen from the Jenna torturers
used to shop there like she would be in
there every now and then that was like
the only place that you could get
anything cool party where you guys would
know that band she's a local around here
we run into her all the time yeah we've
yes I've seen her at shows like several
times and I've seen her perform like
lots of times around here cuz she's from
she still looks the same too she does
she doesn't look like she's aged at all
it's like super freaky so laquetta as I
said you know going to bars up and down
Good Old North Ridge wood and you know
kind of hung out with a bad crowd like
you do down there um she had five kids I
think but she hadn't seen them in a
while and what ended up happening with
her is that ever so every year on
Christmas Eve she had this tradition she
had a friend named Stacey and her and
Stacey would like get together at one of
their houses like on Christmas Eve and
they would kind of like you know have a
good time have a couple drinks and then
they would like you know start preparing
like a bunch of food like for the next
day you know they could celebrate
Christmas together cuz I guess neither
of them had family in the area
so before that occurred though laquetta
said that she was going to this bar
called Chubby's which i don't think is
there anymore I think I remember it but
I don't think it's anymore it's a corner
North Beach Street and Madison Avenue if
anyone
there if anyone knows loser so she
decided she was gonna go to the bar and
then she would come back to Stacy's
house and they would do their regular
thing except she never came back from
Chubby's so her friend Stacy was kind of
pissed off because she thought that oh
well she just like you know blew me off
on Christmas Eve and that was like our
tradition and everything like that so
she stayed up waiting for her but she
never showed up so then Christmas day
kind of comes and goes without her
hearing anything from laquetta then on
the day after Christmas they found
laquetta Gunther's body in an alley off
of North Beach Street which was within
walking distance cuz yeah I'm trying to
think of where that is but yet a car was
somebody that's within walking distance
of Chubby's where she was last seen
alive but just she got in the car with
somebody yeah well probably yeah
so making some money so they actually
found her she was cut in the alley that
was like kind of like a it was like a
little hole or like a little tiny alley
like where you could like stick the but
it was the body was like stuck in
between their like in this little gap
like in the wall she was found naked
except for a pair of socks so again this
is a signature this killer has usually
leaves with victims with just socks on
or shoes so they think that maybe it's
like a foot fetish take the clothes with
it evidently because they don't usually
find them now interestingly for a serial
killer
this guy shoots people you could with a
40 caliber pistol revolver with 14 I
call it 40 yeah yeah it's a pistol
automatic yeah so she was shot in the
back of the head what in what the FBR of
the what the police called
execution-style yeah now all right which
that infers that he's outside yeah you
don't shoot a person inside your car
well not if you're smart yeah he's
taking her somewhere they're getting out
and he's [ __ ] popping them yeah
now the next victim was named Julie
green and she was 34 years old she was
originally from Jacksonville she had two
kids she again she had had jobs like to
start with I think she'd worked as like
a dog groomer and like gardening and
things like that but then got into crack
cocaine and then started working as a
prostitute so like laquetta she often
like walked up and down North Ridgewood
Avenue and hung out in the bars there I
think they might have even known each
other she hung out at a bar called
Willie's place which I think that might
still be there
I haven't been to back to Daytona in a
while and I haven't German unbirth
Ridgewood in many years but I remember
it being there last time I was there
that's on Madison Avenue so yeah so the
two of them were friends heard that
these two victims
yeah Daytona Free People have never been
at Daytona Daytona sounds like it'd be
like a really fun hip place you know cuz
damn the 500 their you know race isn't
[ __ ] Daytona is boring there's not a lot
to do there boy unless you're nice
houses there there's some nice
neighborhoods but most of it's just kind
of boring unless you're into NASCAR yeah
or if you're into like Harley's and like
biker culture yeah because they have
like two big you know things have Bike
Week and Biketoberfest so if you're into
that or if you're into like you know
beachy [ __ ] like fishing and boating and
stuff there's a lot of that type of
stuff going on but other than that it's
kind of like it's real redneck II like a
lot of its kind of redneck II yeah you
think it'd be like metropolitan and
sophisticated or something it's really
not I mean it's better than it was when
I was growing up like it's growing up
it's grown a lot like they're building a
lot around I wouldn't even call it
redneck yeah just call it almost hick
yeah it is there any kind of hick yeah
they also got something there called the
Cabbage Patch was that's like a [ __ ]
famous biker hangout yeah yeah I wrote
down there once and if you if you pass
it it's like nothing but I looked at him
and that's it
yeah it's like not it's like hardly even
a building it's just like it's tiny
like an outhouse or something like
bigger than that but you know that's
what yeah it's that's what I mean you
have to be into that particular like old
fat guys on Harley's like you know
listen to classic rock I went out there
says maybe I'll go have a drink out
there yeah and I got there is in the
afternoon saw mama Buell yes and on the
lightning and I got there and I went
this is it
[ __ ] this yeah I think I wonder if
people come from life because people
come from like all over the country to
go to that to go to Bike Week and stuff
and it's like you know we have like half
a million people we had like half a
million people come and it's like so I
always wonder if people have said I've
never been there and they hear like a
tales of all these like biker bars get
everything they see them and they're
like what like this dinky ass little
about this yeah it looked like a did
look like a damn I'm from the outside of
it looks like a [ __ ] like a ice cream
shack yeah it's really small yeah and I
mean looks like an old Dairy Queen yeah
and I mean during Bike Week they do
they'll build like an outdoor stage and
they'll have like you know they'll set
booths up and [ __ ] like that and they'll
have like you know the big tanks so like
the naked girls can yesil in them if
there was a bunch of mics there I would
have stopped but there's nobody there
yeah but yeah well you didn't go during
Bike Week no just I would not advise
going there during Bike Week or
Biketoberfest because the traffic is
because like I said I mean Daytona is
not really that big a place and you get
like half a million people extra yeah
and it's like it sucks too because what
sucks for me most was I used to live
over because if Daytona is like there's
a mainland and then you know there's the
Halifax River and then there's like a
little strip of land where the beaches
and like you know it's only like a
couple of blocks so I used to live like
most of my life I lived on the mainland
but for a little while like when I was
in high school I lived on the beach side
and whenever you had like I lived almost
right by my high school and like right
behind where the beach was like I could
literally like see the beach from my
window and whenever it was spring break
because yeah and then you get like half
a million drunken stupid college
students
peeing in your yard and stuff yeah so
that was super not fun and you couldn't
go anywhere like as soon as you like
pulled out of your driveway there's like
cars everywhere there's idiots
everywhere it's like it was a nightmare
just a small places nothing it's really
not I mean I think the population I mean
this is kind of misleading but like the
population of Daytona Beach itself is
probably only fifty to sixty thousand
people but that doesn't take into
account because there's like all these
other towns like kind of around it it's
like you know there's because I lived in
Holly Hill there's Port Orange there's
you know Daytona Beach Shores
you know there's Ormond Beach you know
it's kind of place where you would think
by the name that there would be some
cool goth clubs there or some kind of
cool dance clubs they're not no there's
pretty much nothing
redneck bars redneck bars hick hick bars
like I said it's better than it used to
be when I was in high school there was a
couple of punk clubs and like one really
really tiny like kind of coffee house
type place where like bands playing
chick as my brother used to be and punk
bands but um and there's that one place
remember our friend our friend Dimitri
DJ did that one place there oh yeah the
Seabreeze yeah that was Donna mm-hmm
yeah member we drove all the way well he
drove all the way so that's like better
than it used to be it used to be yeah we
don't have anything like that I mean
when I was growing up there the big
place like if you were gonna go out
clubbing was rocking ranch Oh should
yeah
Orlando blows it away well yeah that's
why even we were growing up if we could
get a ride we would always come over
here we never like there was just
nothing to do there was nothing to do so
it's like yeah it's a boring ass down
all right so where was I lost my place
okay so Julie green is the second victim
now she her nickname was [ __ ] now she
was known as what they would call
hustler meaning you had to watch her cuz
she's like stealing your money if he
weren't watching um so she was as far as
I know she was last seen using a
payphone along Tomoka Road and she had a
friend that was waiting for her not too
far away I don't think she could
at the time but she was kind of waiting
for her to get make a phone call and
then come back but she never came back
body was found on January 14 2006 the
body was actually found by a
construction worker they were working
near LPGA Boulevard which is like about
a mile from where I used to live it's
like right off i-95 mmm
like you know right off i-95 in there
and they're building like a bunch of
[ __ ] there because we just went to
Daytona I went there a couple months ago
like to visit my brother and cuz he
still lives over there and I was amazed
at like how much they were building like
out by I doubt by i-95 there's like all
kind of new [ __ ] out there and I was
just like freaking out but yeah so
that's where they found the body they
found her like kind of dumped in this in
a ditch like near a construction site
she had also been shot in the back of
the head execution style with a 40
caliber revolver um yeah so she had
actually I got a feeling they don't know
what's coming maybe not yeah this guy
might be necrophiliac he's getting them
after they're dead yeah yeah maybe maybe
yeah maybe it's the kind of thing where
you just want him around or that you
know they don't really want it yeah
they've taken a closed-off something he
walks in behind pow yeah they may not
even know it's coming yeah
now police did actually find tire tracks
near where the body was dumped and they
were able to identify these tire tracks
as coming from a 2003 Ford Taurus or
possibly a Mercury Sable and they said
that these were factory tires meaning
they had not been changed out since the
car had been purchased so you know oh
that's worth yeah I'm just saying now
interestingly that reported reportedly
and according to her friends Julie Green
seemed to think that someone was after
her like before she was killed she
supposedly she wrote a from a letter to
her boyfriend who was in prison at the
time
and his name was Mitch and she wrote him
a letter that said something about him
getting out March 3rd and she said that
she said I need help
been up for days sorry about the writing
very tired if anything happens to me
smiley knows all so she said that in the
letter so the letter gets you know the
cops are investigating it now they found
out that she had written this letter
about the same time that she had kind of
been accused of stealing from an
acquaintance of hers might have been
drug money might have been something
like that so they found out that smiley
was this guy like a friend of hers whose
name was Rick mark hot now he ended up
going to jail
not too long after the murder because he
had violated his parole for some other
crime that he had done now they did
question him for the murder because of
her thinking like that she was afraid of
him but it doesn't seem like you know it
didn't really seem like anything to do
with it um she might have been on these
drugs in a week for three or four days
like she said might have been half crazy
yeah and I mean she might have been if
the thing about it is she might have
been afraid of smiling because she stole
drug money from him but that doesn't
mean that he was the guy that killed her
that might have just been a coincidence
I got a feeling that whoever's killing
these girls knows them from the bars
yeah I feel like it's somebody that yes
somebody no one trusts frequent well
this might be somebody that's frequent
yeah it's a regular I mean I think they
do have like a profile of this guy but
you know I know just somebody that they
know and trust yeah they've done
business with this person or never met
they're hung out this person before yeah
they don't see him as a threat that's
probably what it is
now that was usually what it is yeah now
there was something else that was
attached to the letter that Julie had
sent to her boyfriend and she had like
it was a picture like a photograph and
it was of Julie and another woman like
apparently
friend of hers and the note on the
picture says find her she can help but
they never did find out who that other
girl in the picture was like they know
one of them was Julie obviously but the
other girl they don't know who that is
so that's again another really weird
thang yeah they don't know and they
don't know if it is well but I mean like
I said you have to explore every avenue
like that because you never know now the
next victim was named Awana Patton she
was originally from Buffalo New York but
lived in Holly Hill which was where I
mostly lived she was um not a prostitute
that I know of but she had actually
worked at an assisted living facility
she was a nurse she had been arrested
for prostitution before but they weren't
like a long time ago but they weren't
sure if she was still doing it she had
like a regular job but apparently it
didn't really pay all that much because
she was still like picking up her mail
at like the local homeless shelter and
stuff has assisted living nurses she
might've sadly does not pay all that but
she might have been making some sad yeah
probably so um she did kind of like hang
out by the homeless shelter it might be
the one that I'm thinking of probably
because it's in that area now her
brother actually happened be a cop here
in Orlando now also it want a new Julie
Green they think so a lot of these girls
were friends or like at least kind of
knew each other because they all hung
out in the same bars and everything like
that and they didn't like been over to
each other's houses and part of the same
scene yeah it was it tell you exactly a
killers in that scene - yeah probably
yeah now she had also uh you know she
went missing and then February 24th 2006
police get an anonymous phone call that
came from a pay phone at a gas station
on Bill France Boulevard which is not
too far from the Speedway um
and the person that called said that him
and his girlfriend had found a body so
he gave the cops the location the body
but would not give his name for
identification or anything like that he
said we were just out for a walk away
found the body by so they found a wanna
Patton's body on a dirt
near Mason Avenue and Williamson
Boulevard not far from the Daytona Beach
Police Department also down the bridges
from i-95 she had also been shot in the
head with a 40 caliber revolver she had
actually looked like she had struggled
unlike the other ones so she might have
like turned and seen you know I think
she was actually maybe shot in this side
at the front of the head not the back of
that so I think she maybe knew something
was up like the other women I don't
really know because it didn't look like
they struggled so it just looked like
somebody snuck up behind him and shot
him now from this particular scene they
found semen so they were able to get a
DNA profile so they do have a DNA
profile of this killer they also found a
shell casing and were able to identify
the specific weapon as a 40 caliber
Smith & Wesson Sigma Series ve yeah
unfortunately kind of like Smith &
Wesson's version of it of a Glock wasn't
quite as successful as clotting on the
market but it was actually a good pistol
you can get him cheap now yeah used ones
yeah they're not they were they were
kind of like an off-brand in a way
because like man Glock owned that
plastic frame gig yeah I mean then Smith
got into it they wanted the plastic
frame gig but you has kind of had this
weird feeling that you were buying an
imitation Glock yeah but you know Sigma
was outright cops used some cops used it
but they ended up on the used market for
cheap yes probably he got it yeah yeah
like you said that's a pretty common
there's lot they made a lot of yeah yeah
they actually ended up finding a wanna
Patton's car a few days after her body
was found it was parked behind a speech
therapy center near Ridgewood Avenue and
this was like right around the same area
where the other two women like hung out
like where all the bars weren't stuff
like that now as I said pretty much from
the beginning you know they knew that
these crimes were linked just because
they you know they're very similar a lot
of the bodies were dumped in similar
types of areas they had all been shot
with
the same weapon it appeared and all the
women had either were either currently
or had previously worked as prostitutes
and all hung out in the same area so
after the investigation into these three
and like I said they pretty much knew
from the beginning that they were linked
they started developing a profile of the
probable killer now according to the
Florida Department of Law Enforcement
particularly Special Agent Tom Davis he
seems to think that this is this killer
is probably a white dude that he
probably has a girlfriend or a wife that
either gives him a lot of grief or that
he has a lot of resentment for and that
he is taking it out on prostitutes or on
these other women they think that he has
a regular job and like a regular life
but that he frequents prostitutes and
hangs out in these bars like on the
down-low so they think that he's
probably an acquaintance or a regular
customer of these women but that but
that he's probably really good at
blending in like he probably seems like
a normal person like he's probably
married he probably has a normal job all
this other kind of [ __ ] and I'm gonna
say he's gone now he may be because he
did kind of stop suddenly
well he probably knows about that DNA
that they got yeah that DNA then you
better you better disappear yeah that's
true yeah he's probably was staying home
but they think that he's kind of gonna
be one of those guys that probably goes
to hookers all the time but that when
when something well that when something
bad went on in his life like he was
particularly stressed out one day he
would kill them if they ever have reason
to take his blood now match him with
that DNA he's a goner yeah so fast he
might stay home yeah yeah well yeah well
yeah they also think that he might have
some kind of foot fetish like I said or
some kind of thing because many of the
victims
because I think all the victims were
found like with just their socks on like
they were naked except they still have
socks on he's up that scene he's local
yeah that's what they're thinking
they're like this is somebody that
visits prostitutes or hangs out at that
same place but is kind of keeping it on
the DL yeah that's what their [ __ ] went
down and he didn't disappear he stayed
in the area yeah going to the same clubs
over and so he could pick up from the
street what was happening see he keep
his ear to the ground and not and he
didn't want to disappeared and look
conspicuous yeah then over a period of a
few years he kind of faded away that's
probably what happened yeah heaps [ __ ]
he could be listening to the show right
now yeah I've [ __ ] him up but as I
said they do have this dude's DNA and so
they're like okay well he doesn't match
anyone's you know because after a
certain year like if you're arrested you
know and you get of a felony then they
will take your DNA right yeah so they're
like if he has ever been arrested it was
either before that or he's never been
arrested for anything he's never been
arrested he can't be arrested if he's
arrested they take his DNA he's [ __ ]
yeah because they really they've tested
like a whole bunch of other people in a
rescued DNA it arrested though I think
they take your DNA after a conviction
that can when you're processing into
prisons I think it depends on the state
I mean I'm not like please correct me if
I'm wrong I'm not entirely sure but I
think like the state laws are different
I was him I wouldn't be sleeping too
soundly at night because if we this show
right here we found out that all's it
takes is one of your cousins or one of
your distant relatives to go to the one
of those damn DNA search it was it the
Hannity search program yeah like
whatever that and then now all of a
sudden based on their DNA that comes up
and goes hey this person's got a second
cousin that killed that killed somebody
yeah you know their DNA is on match
there's no on record well D'Angelo yeah
and they're sure they've caught other
ones to use just the most famous because
now that that worked that time like for
that [ __ ] they're just kind of
likable [ __ ] whoo
they're gonna do it for everything now
you can't get away with this [ __ ] like
talking about it not like it was back in
the day yeah like I said and I was like
you know we were talking about this last
time what's like blood chemistry but I
yeah and I was kind of and I was talking
about this on the conspiratorial show
she was just like the types of crimes
that you see yes there are still serial
killers obviously because you know this
guy this wasn't that long ago but it
really you don't see the same types of
serial killers you also don't see the
longevity they don't last as long
exactly
yeah it's like you don't see one that's
killed like 30 people 50 people and like
for years and years and they don't get
caught no it's like all you do is just
have a second or third cousin go to the
damn Internet and send them to drop of
blood to try to figure out where Europe
they come from
yeah and boom all of a sudden the cops
are like and that's the thing you can't
what's your second cousin's name yeah
that kind of [ __ ] you know because
that's and in a way that's kind of like
what's interesting about how D'Angelo
got caught because it wasn't like they
took someone's DNA I mean someone
uploaded their DNA like willingly
because they were looking for something
else and it just so happened
triangulated them that they triangulated
it down to his stupid ass yeah you know
and they did have to like back it up cuz
they did to like steal [ __ ] out of his
garbage and stuff like that but it's
like it was a clue that got got you to
their to got them to your doorstep yeah
and they're going through your garbage
and looking for the things you threw in
the garbage yeah get that to match it
with your DNA I think probably the best
course of action would be not to be a
serial killer and then you don't even
want to worry about it yeah make sure
like so much easier sleep at night
that's what I mean how could you I mean
it's like I don't understand it well
like I said you know that's the reason
they're sherrilyn killers not because
they're a [ __ ] psychopath
yeah I'd be thinking that the SWAT teams
got busted what busted the wall at any
money might not yeah you might not be
too far wrong you know yeah you never
know when they're gonna get you yeah I
don't know why you'd want to live with
that kind of stress man yeah I just I
don't know I got enough stress in my
life and I'm not even a serial killer so
it's like I can't even I would never get
any sleep or anything you're like
[ __ ] hell
okay so now for a while they were
actually questioning police officers in
the area about these crimes so there's
been rumors swirling it's because of our
years that this might be a cop or an
ex-cop because of that pistol
yeah forty caliber and the Sigma was you
know 40 caliber so this is a law
enforcement caliber especially back in
those days it's been kind of retired for
most departments down because the we
gotta do is just look at it videos of
body cams of police shootings it doesn't
matter if they're using forty or nine
millimeter those cops just the unleash a
hailstorm of [ __ ] rounds on a
perpetrator adrenaline you know yeah so
it doesn't matter what caliber it is as
long as it can penetrate tonight
millimeters good enough it's cheap you
know yeah so they kind of retired forty
forty is a good caliber you know some
people were like well it's in between 45
and nine-millimeter it is and it's more
powerful than 45 it's more powerful than
nine-millimeter especially in certain
loads it's like a light 10 millimeter so
you know the cops really they just went
more for low recoil and just more
capacity you know yeah because it
doesn't recoil as much you can fit an
extra three or four of them in your
pistol magazines you know but it was
it's a good cartridge and the Sigma was
used by certain law enforcement agencies
I believe for a while and yeah forty was
and what year did this happened 2005 to
2007 I was still during the heyday of 40
and well that might be one of the
reasons that they're suspecting that it
might be a cop and the Sigma was you
know some some law enforcement guys used
it I think some agencies may have had it
the only reason why the Sigma got kind
of pushed to the rear is because it
didn't get updated and it was never
updated for modern accessories like you
know lights to hang underneath it and
certain optics you know he didn't have
picatinny rails on the bottom of it
never really a gun you got they stopped
making them before things started to
become kind of standardized in the
pistol world so you can get them used
cheap now because nothing modern can go
on it's hard to get it yeah you know
those little tactical lights and all
that [ __ ] you know it's hard to get hard
to get that to fit on so on a sigma now
but they came from a time before all
that or proprietary rails you know some
of the guys in the chaldeans know what
I'm talking about but uh in those days I
don't think the Sigma was a bargain
pistol it was you know still a pretty
full price pistol I wouldn't necessarily
call it Tier one but yeah maybe it was a
Smith it's okay you know I think most
guys like SIG's and Glocks and you know
there were SIG's out there so I'm
thinking maybe thought that that might
be a cop yeah or a former cop or or
maybe a cop groupie like some of the
others that we've been talking about
although that's hard it's hard to tell
because you know what I mean you can
find you know guys with HKS and SIG's
and exotic weapon trees and they don't
have anything do the law enforcement
yeah you know if you have enough money
you can buy it they might have some
other reasons for a suspect and maybe
some reason kind of like he maybe they
think he's a cop because he's
comfortable in that environment is
comfortable carrying a gun in that
environment maybe they maybe they detect
that he knows a little bit of law
enforcement investigative techniques
yeah although the guy left his DNA
behind so yeah mistake I think it's just
a regular dude yeah probably yeah so
let's talk a little bit about like I
said other than been pinging that he's a
cop and like rumors about that there
were like a couple of leads couple
suspects [ __ ] like that
so in 2006 a little later on after the
third murder so this woman reports to
police that she thinks the killer might
be her ex-husband he had a history of
violence he was a paranoid schizophrenic
etc etc now she claimed the
her ex-husband had admitted to her that
he had shot a woman at close range which
you know that sounds kind of suspicious
now the cops put her in protective
custody and then went in her house and
took like all this DNA supposedly that's
supposed to be his DNA
however this DNA did not match the
sample that they had on file now
another suspect that they looked into
was this homeless guy named David Gibson
Lindsey who actually went by the name
rich Lindsey now evidently he had been
convicted of killing his wife in 1988 he
actually beat her up and then suffocated
her with a plastic bag he got sentenced
to 19 years in prison but he was let out
in 1997 now after he was let out they
think that he killed another guy like an
old man named Austin Runyon in 2001 who
was strangled and beaten to death now
this was in Illinois so after that crime
happened and I guess he was like a
suspect in it and he [ __ ] took off
and went and lived in Daytona Beach and
he was like hanging out like living in a
homeless shelter he was like living as a
homeless person like trying to escape so
he was arrested in June of 2006 because
there was a warrant out for him
obviously because he had like you know
run away from Illinois and he was they
were gonna extradite him back to
Illinois and they took his DNA while he
was in custody but he was also not a
match to the killer now he did get
extradited back to Illinois and stand
trial to stand trial for the other [ __ ]
that they thought like killing the old
guy like I said he did get convicted of
killing his wife but he only served
eight years of a 19 year sentence for
whatever reason so basically they're
getting nowhere they're like catching
people their kid they have suspects and
[ __ ] but they still haven't found a DNA
match now interestingly or
there was another murder a fourth one
even after all this like DNA [ __ ] was
going on now this was a 30 year old
woman named Stacy gage she lived in
Holly Hill like I said where where I
also lived she had actually dropped out
of high school and had two kids by the
time she was 21 years old she was
actually they did not think she was a
prostitute although she was a drug
addict she was addicted to crack and she
had been arrested on you know drug
possession charges and various things
like that she had been trying to kind of
you know get out of it but she kept
falling back into drugs again and you
know so she was really struggling with
it she had two kids that were you know
in elementary school and she was really
trying to get her life back together now
December 10th 2007 she Stacy borrowed
her grandmother's vehicle which was a
Plymouth Voyager which it's a minivan in
it I think so so she just wanted to
borrow the car she was gonna go to like
go to the Publix and get some ice and
some groceries and [ __ ] like that
now she was seen on the public on public
tsa's security cameras you know just
going about her business but after that
she was never seen again um as I said
they're not sure if she was a sex worker
or not but they're saying maybe it's a
possibility maybe she had set up a date
with somebody like on [ __ ] Craigslist
or something like that there's no way of
knowing so they didn't know where she
was for several weeks afterward however
they did find her body On January 2nd
2008 now interestingly she was actually
kind of found by accident because a cop
had pulled over like to do some
paperwork and [ __ ] in his car so he just
happened to pull over like on the side
of this road somewhere like near an old
church and he rolled down the window and
smelled something decomposing and she
was only about 15 yards off the side of
the road she had just been like left
there by the church
so she was like really decomposed so
they weren't entirely sure they did know
that she'd been shot in the head just
like the other victims they could not
you know definitively determine whether
it was the same gun just because she was
so decomposed but it's possible it was
the same one they said it was either a a
40 caliber 45 or 32 now they did not get
any DNA this time they did estimate that
she had died somewhere around December
11th which was the day after she was
seen they did find the minivan about a
week afterward on January 9th
it was in an apartment complex like the
parking lot of an apartment complex on
South Beech Street which is he took it
drove around yeah he might have driven
it around for a while he dumps it in a
place where no one would be looking yeah
which is in well an old apartment
complex well no it was like it was
actually full like it was a college
students nor unit Street that might be
Embry Riddle student yeah you could like
hide in plain sight nobody would know
yeah they did ask like a bunch of the
students there like did you guys see
this van and they said that it had been
there for about a month but that no one
really thought anything about it because
they didn't know who it belonged to so
it was just parked there for a month and
they didn't worry about it right so for
a little while in 2008 they had you know
the Daytona Beach Police Department and
whatnot had like a task force to
investigate these four connected murders
they did DNA tests on you know really
had volunteers with DNA tests they had
[ __ ] you know all the criminals and
stuff that they could get their hands on
the DNA tested none of them were a match
so they feel like this guy either just
stopped or moved somewhere else
now interestingly the Orlando Sentinel
published a an article about unsolved
murders in Florida back in 2010 and they
talked a lot about the Daytona Beach
killer and they're speculating that and
this was also around the same time that
the FBI started that highway crimes
initiative or whatever it was where
they're talking about like the Long
Island serial killer and stuff yeah and
the Orlando Sentinel pointed out that
you know
there have been 19 unsolved murders
along the i-4 corridor which if you're
not from Florida goes all the way across
the state from Daytona to Tampa you know
and goes through Orlando so they are
speculating that there might that this
might be a trucker you know what I mean
because this kind of does [ __ ] that's
happened a lot now some people have also
kind of tried to tie the Daytona Beach
killer in with the Long Island serial
killer saying maybe it's the same person
because they said now when there was
gaps in the Long Island serial killer
case like when there were gaps in when
the when the killings happened then
there were some down here you know I
mean again after they stopped like he
was moving back and forth I mean it
could be but who knows could just be
statistical might be more than one guy
yeah and some people have thought to
that the Long Island serial killer is
more than one person and that that just
happens to be like a really good dumping
ground and that more than one person is
using that and like for sure I mean we
did a show about it before but like for
sure that one the one woman that ran
away from the house and then they ended
up finding her that's how they ended up
finding all the other bodies because she
ran off and then they found her dead
later I don't even think she was
murdered and she might have just been
that might have been an accident no they
found out where the killings are taking
place they're finding the bodies yeah
but are they killed they're just dumped
there see I think they're just dumped
there right it seems like because
nobody's reporting any gunshots yeah 40
Smith & Wesson's loud yeah no you know I
mean people [ __ ] fire off rounds all
the time in the United States and no but
nobody ever reports it well because you
don't necessarily firecrackers are a car
backfiring or something like that it's
like that's the first thing you would
think you wouldn't think that somebody
was shooting up the place unless unless
you live in a really bad neighborhood
right and they ignore it they're used to
it well yeah there's like oh there goes
yeah yeah yeah knock it off doesn't
because cuz you hear shots doesn't mean
people are shooting each other yeah
that's a misconception I mean and you
would a lot of times I just shooting off
into the air yeah yeah so yeah so like I
said some people have been attempting to
link this and say that this is maybe a
truck driver somebody that travels
around and maybe that's why the Daytona
Beach killer's
stopped doing what they were doing now
there were a couple of other unsolved
murders in the Orlando area that they
speculate might have been related
although the mo was slightly different
July of 2007 there was a 37 year old
woman named Kelly lanthorn and she was
killed in Orlando she was also found
naked there was also another victim who
was named Regan Kendall she was 48
now she was found in August of 2007 near
Kissimmee which is about where Disney
World is now she had been dismembered so
that seems a little bit different
because it seems like the Daytona Beach
killer was just like a rape Amanda where
did they find her uh just almost a field
he has a field which she wrapped up or
the bodies to do the body parts just
there don't know cuz dismembered they
did that to make it easier to carry yeah
most likely yeah you would think yeah
and then there was uh it was done
probably like in an apartment yeah
that's usually in the tub or something
yeah yeah I think it's usually
dismembered but as a sign of that it
happened in an apartment yeah because
you can't just like be outside like
cutting someone up well it happens in an
apartment and you can't get the body out
hole without being noticed yeah the pass
everybody's you know ya carry something
that looks like a body then you're going
yeah and then you're going down into
like a parking lot
it attracts too much attention so here
it's just garbage let me throw it from
my shoulder like that so cut him into
smaller parts and just put him in damn
bags yeah you know take him out little
by little well like I said that [ __ ]
case we were talking about the other day
where they just like cut up eyes and
just put them out with the garbage and
they never wrong about him yeah yeah
it's like the ease sometimes the easiest
[ __ ] is like that yeah the [ __ ] that you
get away with him in a garbage yeah you
just put him on the side of the road the
garbage truck takes him away and you
like ya even think about it
yep crazy now there was another one this
actually happened in Casselberry which
is not that far from where we are right
now this was a 39 year old woman named
Lisa Marie French and she had actually
she used to work in Daytona so they
think there might
some link there as well although she had
been strangled they think they said she
was kind of decomposed when she was
found so they weren't able to establish
cause of death of any certainty but they
think she might have been strangled now
they think they caught the guy that did
that but they're not sure if he was the
Daytona Beach killer or not so they
caught this guy named Jerry Lee Williams
who he was a serial rapist now they
think that he attacked at least six
women between 2003 to 2007 now he did
plead guilty to killing Lisa Marie
French and he got life in prison so like
I said it's possible that that's the
same person cuz she did have like links
to Daytona but the mo was kind of
different so not really sure now one guy
who they're kind of looking at with a
lot of interest for these particular
cases is this guy named one David Ortiz
now in September of 2018 in Laredo Texas
for sex workers were murdered there as
well
29 year old Melissa Ramirez 42 year old
Claudine and Lew era 35 year old
Griselda Alicia Hernandez Cantu and 28
year old Nicky and Rica's who was
actually a transgender woman now these
four sex workers were also shot with a
40 caliber handgun so they are
speculating that this guy might have
been living in Daytona and then killed
these four women and then he moved to
Laredo Texas and he's doing the same
[ __ ] over there I know but I mean that's
just the main law enforcement caliber in
what in what years were these again well
now the Daytona ones were 2005 to 2007
now the Texas ones were 2018 you okay
it's you know 40 is still out there yeah
it's still out there and it's very
common and a lot of used police pistols
hit the market you can get very high
quality tier 1 pistols out there used
for cheap yeah yeah ex-police pistols
you know you can get
nice [ __ ] Smiths and everything you
know but can even Glocks in 40 because
the the you know most your Police
Department's kind of dropped 40 so you
can get high quality forties on the
right on the surplus market yeah so
that's it's just a coincidence forty is
almost is almost as common as
nine-millimeter now yeah so maybe but I
know me there's almost as common as 22
and it's very common but the thing about
it is that it's not so much just that
the firearm is common but it's like
serial killing is not all that common
and jus kids with guns are not all that
cop and to target sex workers
specifically and they were killed in the
same way it just seems like you've done
a thing to say it's the same fingerprint
I mean yeah I mean I don't know I'm just
saying that's very similar I mean serial
killing is very rare and like you said
serial killing with a firearm
is exceptionally rare yeah they don't
like those no cuz like I said it's a
fetishistic thing usually so they'll use
like a bladed weapon or something like
the hands yeah yeah yeah they usually
strangle or stabbed they don't usually
shoot shoot makes a lot of noise it
tells me that he's got privacy when he's
doing this he's taking up somewhere
maybe so now this guy did get caught
after like I said these four women
turned up dead in Texas now he had
apparently abducted another woman with
the intention of killing her but she got
away and reported him now he was 35
years old at the time which was last
year now he was actually a Navy veteran
he'd been in the Navy from 2001 to 2009
and he so he'd been transferred to a
whole bunch of different military bases
who are on the East Coast and when
Midwest and stuff like that now after he
was discharged he went to work for the
Border Patrol he worked there from 2009
to 2011 ploy II like he'd only he only
had like one very minor like behavioral
infraction or something it's like so no
one suspected him
of anything you know he was also like
very well educated he's married he had a
kid now he did actually confess to the
kidnapping of this one woman and it was
also attempted murder that probably
would and he also admitted to the other
four as well so he he said that he had
used the the forty caliber handgun was
his service weapon it was issued to and
that he had used that to kill all of
them and he said he was what they would
call a mission style killer his aim was
to eradicate all the prostitutes yeah
although that's the excuse that they
give yeah I don't think that's really
what the deal is but he didn't he didn't
confess to the ones at Florida though no
yeah but it's possible that because like
I said he was in the Navy all that time
and he did he was at some different
bases like along the East Coast so it's
possible he could have been living
around there at that time could've Bambi
usually if you're gonna go ahead and
confess to these over here you're gonna
go ahead and confess to the other ones
too because they'll just make your make
your legend larger you know true you
know like I said it you're gonna get
life in prison so yeah you know it just
really does seem like strange that you
got two serial killers running around
that's another one doing the exact same
thing yeah that's even scarier like to
think that it's like it's not even the
same person so yeah um like I said it's
possible it's that guy but who knows and
as far as I know I don't think they've
like compared the DNA cuz it didn't say
anything about that so you'd think that
they would be able they have his DNA and
it didn't match so they would have said
so maybe not yeah man so before we wrap
up the show we'll do one more little
briefcase this is the case of a
briefcase yeah it's a real case yeah
cool this is the Seminole Heights killer
now unlike the other three we'll leave
it on a happy well a sort of happy note
because this guy at least got caught
allegedly he's he hasn't been convicted
yet but I believe he's either way
awaiting trial or he's on trial at the
moment
so the Seminole Heights killer this is a
serial killer believed to have murdered
four people in the Seminole Heights
neighborhood of Tampa Florida in October
and November of 2017 recently now this
is a very interesting serial killer
because he also shot people and he just
picked people at random like it wasn't
even like he'd have a victim profile or
nothing it just seemed like he was just
driving around going hey I'm gonna pop
that just like a spree killer yeah it
was more like a spree killer and it
happened like I said over pretty much so
is that rain right oh my goodness
so the first victim of this killer this
happened on October 9th 2017 about 9:00
p.m. it was a guy named Benjamin Edward
Mitchell which is weird because Edward
Mitchell is my dad's name um he was
waiting at a bus stop in the Seminole
Heights neighborhood of Tampa he was
twenty-two twenty-two years old African
American man and he was basically going
to get on the bus and he was gonna go
see his girlfriend and somebody just
cruised by and shot him next victim but
it was kind of like that yeah so the
next victim was named Monica Cara Dodd
Hoffa this was October 13th um she was
32 years old white female she was
walking to her friend's house and was
shot dead hmm just by somebody walking
by apparently next victim was named
Anthony na boa he was a 20 year old
Hispanic man shot dead about 8:00 p.m.
on October 19th he was actually had some
mental disabilities he had autism and
ADHD and he was actually so he's just
like walking down the street and shot in
the head by someone walking by next
victim was happened on November 14th
this was Ronald Felton he was a 60-year
old man he was just crossing the street
and a
the suspect came up behind him and just
fatally shot him damn well their
witnesses tell this I would assume
because I mean this happened at all
well this happened at almost 5:00 in the
morning the victim was actually going to
he was going to this church that he
volunteer down like he fed the homeless
and stuff so he was going in there early
to like set up yeah and he just blew me
he was just walking across the street
and like somebody just like [ __ ] shot
him so they were able to connect all of
these crimes cuz I mean honestly because
like I said because the victim profile
is so different and people are just like
randomly shot in the street you wouldn't
necessarily think they were all linked
but they were able to figure out that
they were all the same Glock handgun and
so kind of like that hole in this
they're all in the same neighborhood so
pretty much the whole neighborhood is
like freaking out they're all in
lockdown I think it looks like Halloween
happened around that time too so they
were like trying to like monitor
everyone when they were
trick-or-treating and a lot of people
didn't go they put out like a hundred
$10,000 reward leading for information
he wasn't picked up on camera or
anything uh he actually was that's the
next thing I was going to say now two of
the murders the murders of Mitchell and
Felton did show up on surveillance
cameras now the suspect was wearing a
hoodie that looked like they said on the
on the video it looked like colored but
they said well because it's infrared
like it might actually be dark so he
might like I have all black clothing on
because they had another witness that
said they thought that the guy had like
a dark colored hoodie on so the suspect
was described as a black male thin build
light complexion about six to six six
feet to six feet two inches tall now
interestingly um this is really weird so
this guy Howell Emanuel Donaldson the
third he's at the McDonald's that he
works at which is an Ybor City which is
where the castle is nervous guy now yeah
yeah so he works at the restaurant he
tells his manager whose name was de la
de Walker that he's like I
to go to an am Scott to like cash a
check or whatever to get some cash and
then I'm gonna leave town and then he
gives her like a bag with the gun in it
yeah so yes just hold this for me yeah
so she understandably calls the cops
yeah now it just so happened that there
was a cop car in the McDonald's parking
lot at the very time that she called so
they just waltzed right in and arrested
his stupid ass yeah so yeah so they
asked if they could search his car
and he said yeah so they searched the
car they found blood-stained clothing
which looked just the same as you know
the the clothing that had been in the
video and the clothing that had been
described to them they also tracked his
cell phone records and found that he had
been in all the areas you know at the
times when the murders took place like
you know all his locations yes I saw
that
he's a wiry kind of tall wiry jittery
looking [ __ ] and you could tell he's
kind of like a [ __ ] schizo tight real
skittish spree killer yeah I mean you
know you're not talking a criminal
mastermind at all you know he's just
gonna he just worked in McDonald maybe
he was just like walking around shooting
people just for the he's so just for the
[ __ ] of it yeah he's one of those just
one of these numbskulls that somehow got
his hands on thump it on a pistol I
don't think he bought that from from a
store I think yes a friend gave it to
him or something he bought it off of
somebody he knew and and and he was like
when these guys were I'm gonna try this
out I'm gonna try this pistol out it's
something like that it probably was just
like simple as that how it works yeah it
works yeah somebody else oh man it works
wow this works really good you weren't
you weren't dealing with a real bright
God all clear you detail yeah yeah but
yeah so they did some mental problems
yeah obviously yeah but yeah so they did
a ballistics test and they did find out
that it was his Glock that had shot all
of the people so he was arrested now he
has not like he's still awaiting trial
his trial doesn't start until next year
August 20th 2020 yeah so we'll see how
that goes but it does seem like you will
probably get convicted oh yeah I always
like to know like cuz you know every
time and like I read about on solve
cases a lot where they always say oh you
know there's a $100,000 reward yada yada
and you never hear about anybody getting
that but now in this case the manager of
the McDonald's
did you she got it yeah she got the
reward because she called a narc done is
because he's like here hold and she's
like well she's some sketchy [ __ ] we
thought he was a jittery sketchy [ __ ] to
begin with and he wasn't she he wasn't
the kind of guy she thought should have
a gun
yeah like this dis dudes up to some [ __ ]
yeah and he was you know it freaks me
out it's like he didn't have a carry
concealed permit yeah you know it freaks
me out is like you know because we go to
Ybor City from time to time because
that's where the castle is and I used to
go there like pretty much every weekend
it's like I might have been in that
McDonald's yeah I might have been
working there you can't overthink any of
this [ __ ] because it could have any
anywhere at any time
well yeah I know here's another one that
we could be laying up in that bed and
get swallowed up by a sinkhole I think
about that that is this area how whole
houses have yeah managed down into dam
sinkholes and the people never found
yeah I'm gonna do yeah they said yeah he
[ __ ] went down to a sinkhole that's
it his [ __ ] half of his whole house
went into the sink it's like drag me to
hell man that's what it's like seriously
and it appeared just in a few minutes
house was there and then all of a sudden
houses we probably should worry about
that more than getting murdered I with
the house swallowed up by the [ __ ]
earth yeah that's some weird [ __ ] cuz we
cuz [ __ ] underneath Florida it's just
all some bad there's just some bad yeah
well there's just like there there's
like um it's like Coquina Rock and it's
like just there's like holes of pockets
and yeah there's all kind of like and
we're right at the water the water level
like we're right at sea level so if you
go to the beach and like dig down like
two feet there's what I think it was
here in Florida where they had to
abandon that whole city huh what we're
said in Alabama where was that
I can't remember actually poisonous gas
has started coming out
and houses started to you know fall dad
to sinkholes and that is one thing I
worry about because house has
disappeared into sinkholes and then a
whirlpool of water yeah yeah that's
right and then they had to affect that
sounds like some they had to evacuate
like a whole neighborhood thousands of
people
brand-new houses because some noxious
gas is coming up out of people worried
about you know I can understand you know
people worried about pollution nobody
likes pollution or like there's some
[ __ ] noxus ass gases that just come
out of a damn ground noxious ass noxious
gases there's some nice glasses coming
out of some other place yeah you got all
kinds of stuff there man you got tone
you got uranium in there what in the
ground are in your ass yeah maybe well
like I said is I feel like that's
probably like a bigger problem it's you
know living in Florida getting sucked
into a sinkhole getting blown away a
hurricane yeah by the alligator that's
population you got to keep [ __ ] in to in
proper perspective well getting bit by
mosquito with it that's carry that's a
flight yeah and all these weird-ass
tropical diseases that we have
hurricanes yeah tornadoes yeah sinkholes
alligators mm-hmm okay
brown recluse spiders yeah weird [ __ ]
like Ebola this is a great place all we
need is one of these dudes from well yes
from the Congo it's a [ __ ] swamp to
come down in here and just spread Nebo
[ __ ] yeah cuz this is a perfect place
for you both well like I said it's like
a [ __ ] swamp yeah it's all you need
it's like it's just like you know how
when uh you know species get introduced
in the wild like one escaped from the
zoo or something like that Florida is
where they go because they're like oh
it's nice and hot yeah and there's water
everywhere
yeah but boa constrictors now we didn't
have those we have weird kind of
tropical fish that eat up all the other
fish yeah we got it's got an arapaima
but we have arapaima here probably what
is that Brazil
fish that got into these got into the
damn lakes it's not every pie man I
can't it might be like I shot it's like
a giant piranha yeah about the size of a
dinner plate yeah you know teeth on it
that's here you never know what you're
coming earth seriously I will constrict
I've lived here my whole life and a
kindest and pretty much like once a week
like went out when I'm just out walking
along the path I see some like insect or
something that I'm like what the [ __ ] is
that thing I've never seen one of those
got the great white anaconda see oh I'm
not allowed to talk about your butt but
now you're talking okay I see yeah see
he's allowed to do things but are you
done talking about Florida now yeah oh I
should say that like I told you to I
told you that I saw an otter this
morning yeah this is my size big cookie
right yeah it was about baby we saw we
saw an otter a couple months ago
crossing the street going to this pond
right across the street from the house
mmm
well crosses never across treatment out
but crosses kind of around the corner
across the street yeah dad otter had to
be about six feet long that was the big
and it was huge it was long it's low to
the ground but yeah long I would say is
about five feet long with it yeah easily
the tail
yeah yeah it's huge this one he got that
big yes oh man you know side of your
child you don't see him very often but
um every now and then and yeah I was I
was walking this morning like down along
we have like a County path it's looked
really nice there's like trees and [ __ ]
over the top of it and I was walking
along and like there's a pond on one
side that's got like alligators and
ducks of [ __ ] in it and then on the
other side is these woods where
allegedly the people that live or I
think they're growing pot in there we go
because every time like every now and
then I'll walk by and I'm like oh we
passed weed yeah so I call in the
marijuana woods yeah so our ground
something definitely our because that
because it's like that sticky sticky
resin well yeah cuz sometimes I walk
through there I'm like oh they must be
like trying out there for
and their latest harvest I think it's
legal here now Florida um
Florida hmm is it I think I've smelled
weed in the damn clubs before yeah but
that doesn't necessarily make it legal
okay it's like people are doing all kind
of severance it's not legal but yeah so
I was walking and I saw like probably
about 50 feet in front of me this little
critter comes running out of marijuana
woods and goes running down to like the
little alligator pond down there and he
yeah it was like a little bitty powder
it was like a baby one probably or like
a teenage one who's about baby cookie
size I'm always getting so excited when
I see otters that one that we saw was
she oh the one that we saw yeah that was
judge that was the size of a man yes
well it was like it was probably like it
was the size of like a small dog
probably I remember it being about 5
feet long and about that high off the
ground just it was you know it probably
weighed 110 pack and he had like a
really long tail listen this one's tail
was probably about half as long as that
so I think it was probably like but so
yeah I got super excited when I saw it
it's just like it's just like every now
and then when I see a bunny like you
know every now and then you'll see like
a little wild bunny just like in the
[ __ ] woods and I get super excited
about that yeah I know but you know
that's that's one of the ones that we
don't see very often that's one of the
ones we don't see very often bunnies and
otters I haven't seen a bear in a while
now I haven't seen some deer but possums
no bears in a long time and it possible
on top of the fence he sued possums you
know it looks they got a mouth full of
sharp teeth it looks like they'll hurt
you but they're just they're timid
little creatures really they're not well
yeah everything yeah remember that what
remember the other night like well this
was like a few months ago probably but
remember yeah they're but you remember
um we heard like like this horrible
racket like out on the back porch and
like we thought somebody was out there
like trying to break into the [ __ ] and
we look out there it was this big
[ __ ] possum and he was like climbing
around inside our barbeque girl he's
trying to get the barbecue he was trying
to cut it open because we I guess been
barbecued yet we had cooked on it
earlier and I guess he's like what that
smells good I'm gonna say Sookie was
barbecuing he was trying to open he was
a big one he's making so much
I wish we got that on film but it was
like so dark outside we're at bigger
than a cat yeah it was like a baby
trying to get in the grill they're not
dumb they know where the good food is
shut it down can you shut it down
all right I'm shutting it down all right
so hope you enjoyed this rather rambling
discussion of various crimes that took
place in my home state of Florida and
remember if you like the show like share
subscribe on all your social media share
with your friends and family if you'd
like to support show you go to our
patreon page or go to our blog where
there is a little link to a PayPal
account or you can give a one-time
donation if you would like to do that
and where we will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]